[Music]
thousands of migrants are now at this
border encouraged to come to belarus and
then told to try to leave that country
and enter poland
but the reality is that polish police
are blocking their path the polish
government is repelling these migrants
forcefully and says it is defending
itself and the european union
[Music]
the assessment of the situation is clear
the belarusian regime is attacking the
polish border the eu in an unparalleled
manner
these migrants can't get into poland nor
return to belarus instead they're stuck
in a miserable no man's
are extremely grave and devastating
there is a shortage of water and food
and there is no sanitation
the eu blames this man for the mess
alexander lukashenko the belarusian
president elected in very dubious
circumstances
his victory was followed by sanctions on
him his country and his supporters the
eu says his use of migrants as a weapon
is the action of a rogue state it's
proof they say that sanctions are
working
regime starts to behave as a gangster
regime because it's hurting them and
they don't know what else to do so they
try to undermine the european union by
attacking and launching a hybrid attack
against the member states of the
european union
as for lukashenko himself he remains
defined
saying today that it was poland that was
actually the aggressor
said we understand that being in a war
with these poor people on the polish
belarusian border and moving in tank
columns it's obvious that it's some sort
of drill or intimidation
there are other migrants heading from
belarus to lithuania and latvia also eu
member countries and now nervous
look i don't want to scare anyone but
you see the situation at the polish
border as this story has repeatedly
shown we must be prepared for the
various surprises this included
russia an ally of belarus looks on and
as the political rail rages so the
weather gets colder and the conditions
get worse
adam parsons sky news